welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast uh my name is eric trexler i am
the special temporary primary host for
today's episode and i am joined by greg
knuckles uh people have listened to
previous episodes will recognize him
he's been a co-host before and for
today's show he's going to be
for now the the permanent guest co-host
for the time being so greg thank you for
joining me yeah thanks for having me
uh as always if you like the show be
sure to like rate and subscribe wherever
you get it
if you want
more research who doesn't want more
research greg everybody wants more
research you can find it in your email
inbox however
you have to sign up for the newsletter
so go to strongerbyscience.com
newsletter we send out all sorts of
information including regular research
updates uh if you are looking for a
one-on-one virtual coach you can check
that out at strongerbyscience.com
coaching
if you want to get affordable
supplements even cheaper than list price
head over to bulksupplements.com
you can use our discount code sbs pod
that gets you a five percent discount
off of your entire order and in addition
if you'd like to support the show
there's a couple ways you could do that
you could go to the uh the mass research
review and subscribe that's a monthly
research review
where we review all the newest research
in exercise and nutrition science
you could also check out macro factor
that's the diet app that we co-developed
with a very talented team of developers
it does offer a free trial so you can
take it for a spin and see if you like
it before you make any kind of financial
commitment
we're going to dive right in with
today's episode
people noticed that our last episode ran
a little bit longer than our intended
one hour
goal
i am firmly committed in this episode to
keeping my segment well under 90 minutes
um but i am proud that i believe i have
the new record on the show uh and the
record that i set last week was i
went to about 500
of the intended duration of my segment
i i know that no one's gonna believe
this
i genuinely thought i was gonna do that
in about 20 or 25 minutes i i have
literally no idea how that's the case
it's one of those i just looked at the
outline i was like well this is going at
least an hour i looked back at it and
it's weird it was almost like i didn't
think about it at all i was just like oh
i'm sure i can
put this together be really concise and
then i looked back at it i was like just
the introduction was like 17 minutes
yeah so um
yeah i i really believed deep down in my
heart that was a 20 25 minute segment i
thought there was a possibility that it
could stretch to 30. it ended up being
approximately 100 minutes so that is the
um
the record for being just absolutely
delusional on this show and having
no understanding of how time works but
uh this week i'm certain that we're
gonna do better uh also one life update
we uh in a
previous fireside chat we talked a
little bit about facial hair
you encouraged me to grow a beard uh
several listeners did the same
and i am committed to supporting the
audience and doing
literally exactly what they tell me to
so
i am working on a beard if you're if
you're watching on youtube um personally
i i don't think it's going well
but uh you said that if i just i think
it looks good i appreciate it it looks
good
you assured me that if i trust the
process
and uh just stick with it
eventually things will get better so i i
have trust in that i have faith in that
and i'm going to keep pushing forward
with an open mind but at some point i'm
going to have to figure out how to
make it look good uh so so now it's just
kind of laying the foundation letting it
fill in and we'll see what happens i
mean that's that's the key to growing a
long beard you don't have to do anything
to make it look good it's just a matter
of time okay well i i have seen you know
the beard culture has taken on a life of
its own and people have all of the
the oils and the tinctures and the
paraphernalia associated with grooming
it so i guess that you're you're
squarely outside of that that particular
niche of beard culture yeah i shampoo it
and that's that's literally it oh my god
i yeah so last night uh
let me ask you a question greg this is a
genuine question all right
do you know the difference between
shampoo and conditioner
yeah
i see
i got in a really big discussion with my
girlfriend last night
i had no idea
i thought they were the same thing and
it was just like a marketing gimmick uh
and to my credit
you know i have long used something that
claims to be a soap a shampoo and a
conditioner all at once the the classic
three in one yeah so i assume that any
distinction was mostly academic rather
than practical yeah they were basically
the same thing uh
my girlfriend was absolutely stunned she
thought i was doing a bit
she accused me of lying
and my
my claim was that
no more than about 15 of men will know
the difference between shampoo and
conditioner uh
that's that's probably not
entirely wrong i mean there there's this
is my opinion unless you're growing your
hair reasonably long i don't think
there's any reason to know the
difference yeah uh
because
i don't know this this could just be my
perspective but i think if your hair is
less than about
maybe like two inches long like each
individual hair being about two inches
long like
it's not even going to be obvious if
your hair is like dry or not
like if it needs to be conditioned it's
like if you're keeping your hair short i
i just don't think it matters but but i
hear that if you grow your hair long and
don't condition it it gets like dry and
frizzy and yeah what like
that's just not a scenario i've ever had
to worry about yeah so i just go with
the head and shoulders two in one um
[Music]
and it's been fine yeah and that that
was uh the the argument uh it was a
really heated argument it eventually got
to that point where the reason i gave
that 15 number uh was really just a
matter of
you know
how frequently
do people actually try to grow their
hair out to a considerable length like
yeah like for me i'd never
tried to grow my hair super long so
again like it's it's never been
something that has uh
been something for me to navigate
uh
but
she did ask she was like have you ever
noticed that conditioner doesn't like
sud up at all and i was like yeah i just
thought conditioner was like shitty
shampoo yeah like so so i um
i attempted for the span of about a week
to have a more adult grooming routine
where i'd like use some beard oil have
separate shampoo and conditioner
um
and like i
use uh like hand lotion i hate it all of
it um
it just like most things that are
supposed to like moisturize whatever
they're supposed to moisturize they just
make you feel greasy yeah i hate that
yeah like like you use conditioner in
your hair and then
next thing you know like
that drips down over the rest of your
body and now like your whole body feels
like it's just been through an oil slick
yeah and
i think i mean allegedly some people
find that nice and appealing same thing
with like beard oil it's like i feel
like i just went to a [ __ ] kfc buffet
and like ate a bunch of fried chicken
and got chicken grease in my in my beard
which also isn't a great feeling
experience like the
i don't know how it looks or smells to
other people but the tactile sensation
for me
is deeply unpleasant so i i gave that
whole song and dance about a week and
then said no [ __ ] it like that i'm i
can't live this life i'm glad to hear
that that's a generalizable experience
uh because like like i think i've
mentioned this on the show before but
growing up i had like a i wouldn't call
it severe but i had a very moderate case
of tourette syndrome like my symptoms
were notable like it was moderate enough
that like before the school year you
gotta go talk to the teacher and say
here's what's gonna happen this year
yeah right
um but yeah so like for part of my
tourette's uh symptoms
there is considerable overlap with
obsessive-compulsive disorder
and for me texture and like the way my
clothing felt and things like that i was
always very particular about like if i
tied my shoes
one percent too tight or too loose it
would like i couldn't i couldn't get
past it you know so for me i thought
that oily greasy lotion feeling for me
it was a non-starter
but but i'm glad to hear that someone
else feels the same way
yeah i i it's
uh
who knows this could uh be suggestive of
some sort of uh of neurodivergence in
myself as well but especially especially
for me it's my hands like yeah the hands
and feet but mostly hands like if like
how how they are just normally is fine
or like you know i can run them under
water wash them with like normal soap
that's also fine
but any sort of like lotion
dude i i feel like i want to jump out of
a window for the next like two hours it
makes me feel like i'm going insane yeah
same thing if they get too dusty like
dust
and uh yeah and like lotions like they
yeah just just not good yeah i'm with
you man but uh okay
i think in order to stay under two and a
half hours we should probably dive into
the topics here so
greg uh
the floor is yours all right
so i'm gonna start with a question eric
um so if i told you
that i am aiming to maximize muscle
growth for yeah overall for a particular
muscle group doesn't really matter but
i'm aiming to maximize muscle growth
over the next six months and i'm
presenting you with a binary choice
i am either going to do sets of about 10
reps for the muscle group i'm training
or
about 25 30 reps uh which one
would you advise me to do from from an
evidence-based perspective
i'm thinking of a very specific page in
the old manual studying for the cscs
exam
and they had the beautiful little
infographic
you know where it was like this is the
strength range and this is hypertrophy
and this is muscular endurance everybody
went with that forever and then
all the studies came up came out with
the really high high rep low load
training and everybody said throw that
away so the the two options you gave me
i would say
both totally the same no need to sweat
over the details
so that is i think a very justifiable
answer to give and i also think that
it's the wrong answer and it's the
answer i scripted for you so uh
if people are listening don't be like ah
eric's a dumb ass and greg and eric are
about to fight uh no
we we call this a a learning opportunity
apparently there's research on this if
instead of just giving someone the right
answer if you ask someone a question and
they give the wrong answer and then you
can
leverage the shame well not leverage the
shame but in a
uh
in a
thoughtful way
explain why they're wrong in a
non-judgmental way apparently uh people
remember better um i i got that from the
youtube channel veritasium so hopefully
derek wasn't bullshitting with that one
uh but anyway so that's that's what
we're going for here anyway so the
answer you gave uh you know
10 reps 30 reps per set seems to be the
same so
for me as an individual trying to gain
as much muscle as possible
no difference doesn't matter
either one's fine
so that is
an answer that that comports well with
the research where
you know you take two groups of people
put one on one program one on another
program run it for
three months four months whatever
check gains over time
but that may not necessarily be true for
individuals and i think that that's
a point that people intuitively
understand really well in other contexts
but maybe
don't understand quite as well
intuitively when it comes to resistance
training research so here's an example
so let's say someone runs a study on
basketball players in the off season
where you take
you know you you randomly allocate
groups you take one group of people and
say hey this off season all we're doing
is resistance training and we're gonna
try to get you as strong and powerful as
possible the other group you say you
know hey you gotta like you can't get
too exhausted by the end of the game
like we we still wanna be firing on all
cylinders in the fourth quarter when the
other team is fading we want to be able
to leave our starters in the game longer
etc so the entire offseason we're just
going to do conditioning work to try to
get you in as good of shape as possible
if you run that study
and the results are that for the
subsequent season
there's no difference between the two
protocols like the effects on
you know box scores are the same like
points rebounds assists whatever
the effect on advanced stats is the same
you know you could compare those group
means and say hey these were two
similarly efficacious interventions
however i think people who
know anything about basketball
wouldn't therefore assume these two
things work the same on average
therefore they'll work the same for all
individuals so you know if you have a
young bean pole coming into the league
like chet holmgren uh you know it's it's
pretty obvious that he does need to
spend time in the weight room and bulk
up so he doesn't get bullied on the post
so you know for that individual i think
someone could could look at that and be
like well
you know maybe these two interventions
are similarly efficacious on average but
for this person like he definitely needs
to be in the weight room and for someone
else who you know maybe is already quite
big and strong but maybe has
conditioning issues
dominant when they're fresh but you
can't keep them on the court for more
than five minutes at a time people would
look at that person be like okay well
they they need to do conditioning like
the the weight training is fine they're
already strong enough they need to get
in better shape so you know
i think people get that intuitively but
that same principle applies to
resistance training research where
even though at this point we do have
a lot of research suggesting that when
you're when you equate on a per set
basis take sets either to failure or
pretty close to failure on average
moderate rep and high rep sets result in
the same hypertrophy
that doesn't necessarily apply to all
individuals and
i think that that applies in terms of
both content creators and content
consumers so
uh for for content creators if you look
at research and two things look to be
the same on average it's kind of easy to
put the message out there like oh these
two things are the same there's no
difference like
everyone in my audience either one
totally valid option for you it doesn't
matter what you do
um and i think for
for individual consumers as well there's
also kind of uh
an urge to interpret things that way so
even if uh
someone putting out content isn't being
that explicit about it like oh there's
there's absolutely no difference between
these things you know averages
individuals they're the exact same thing
you kind of want to interpret things
that way so i i see this uh play out um
for example like in discussions about
failure versus non-failure training
where
you know
you can look at the research it seems
like ah on average there's not much of a
difference
as long as the non-failure training
isn't just super super easy
but then you know folks will get all up
in arms and be like hey i used to train
to failure all the time i i had bad
gains now i'm doing more like sub
maximal training my gains are a lot
better you know [ __ ] the science it's
all wrong
yeah so
basically you
asked me a question
i give a
fairly standard consensus answer
and you purport to dunk on it
but i know you and i assume that you
have some evidentiary basis for this and
potentially even a specific study that
you'd like to discuss i do in fact have
one so um you know this isn't the only
study that that illustrates the point
i'm trying to make but it's a study that
was published earlier this year so
pretty recent that does illustrate this
point quite well that just because two
things work similarly well on average
that doesn't necessarily mean they'll
work similarly well for all individuals
so the study i'm going to talk about is
by carniero and colleagues the title is
different load intensity transition
schemes to avoid plateau and no response
and lean body mass gain in
post-menopausal women so that's that's a
bit of a mouthful and
we're actually not going to talk much
about the actual topic of the study who
knows might do that next episode uh
because i i think that there's a lot of
confusion about high versus low
responders non-responders as well um so
that that might be a good uh segment for
the future but right now we're talking
about just
inter-individual responses to
uh on average similarly efficacious
training interventions
so in this study uh 24 healthy
post-menopausal women
uh trained for
24 weeks completed a 24-week
intervention
so they were randomly assigned to groups
and one of the groups completed 12 weeks
of low load training followed by 12
weeks of moderate load training so
crossover design
and then the other group completed 12
weeks of
moderate load training followed by 12
weeks of low load training so
both groups completed the same 12-week
block of moderate load training and the
same 12-week block of low load training
just in different orders
um
the training consisted of three sets of
leg press knee extensions leg curls and
calf raises to failure or close to
failure three times per week
the moderate load group did sets of
eight to twelve reps for all of those
exercises every training session or the
the moderate load condition the low load
condition involved doing sets of one of
the more random rep ranges i've heard of
in the literature sets of 27 to 31 reps
i disagree i i always ask my clients
have you have you been doing your 27s
like i told you
uh
i don't think that's common but more
power to you uh and there was a
a progression mechanism in this study as
you would like to see so if a subject
completed more than 12 reps or more than
31 reps during their first set training
loads would be bumped up for their next
training session
uh and this study assessed
lean soft tissue mass of the legs via
dexa pre-training mid-training so at the
point where people were transitioning
between
loading schemes
and post-training
and the group averages
were perfectly in line with the rest of
the research so
uh in if you're watching on youtube
we'll we'll flash the graphic up on the
screen here but gains in lean soft
tissue mass of the legs which was the
proxy for hypertrophy in the study uh
were
virtually identical with low load and
moderate load training on average
for both groups so
you know not just between groups but
also within groups they seem to be on
average very very similar
training stimuli to on average promote
gains in
muscle muscle mass of the legs
however since this was a crossover study
that means we can also see how well
individuals responded to both low load
and moderate load training and again if
you're watching on youtube we'll we'll
flash the graphic up here
so on average uh subjects gained about
three and a half four percent uh lean
soft tissue mass of the legs during both
of the 12-week training blocks but the
the individual responses were were all
over the place so
uh kind of on the most extreme end there
was one person who had a five percent
decrease in lean soft tissue mass of the
legs following moderate load training
which is not good that's not what you
want to see
and an increase in excess of 10
following low load training so that
person did
tremendously better with low load
training the moderate load training
and then just for another example
someone had like a 13 increase in lean
soft tissue mass of the legs following
moderate load training and like a three
percent increase following low load
training so they did
tremendously better with moderate load
training
so you know those are the sorts of
within individual differences that can
be lurking beneath the surface
following two training interventions
that on average are similarly effective
um
so also if you're watching on youtube
we'll throw up another visual here that
uh expresses the same information in a
slightly different way so
it's a scatter plot showing the
relationship of how much muscle someone
gained during their first 12 weeks of
training versus how much muscle they
gained during their second week second
12 weeks of training
with the different training protocol
and so if the two training protocols
were equally effective for all
individuals what you would expect to see
is just a set of points that fell along
the line that could be expressed as x
equals y so just
a straight diagonal line passing through
the origin going up and to the right
with the points being pretty clustered
around that line and a strong positive
association
between how well you did with one
training protocol and how well you did
with the other training protocol
uh what we see is that there's basically
no correlation and if a correlation
exists it's a weak negative correlation
where
uh you know essentially how well you do
on one how how well you did with
moderate load training didn't predict
how well you'd do with low load training
and vice versa and if anything and i i
wouldn't read into this virtually any at
all but if anything doing really well
with moderate load training was slightly
negatively predictive of doing well with
lolo training um the beautiful thing
about being the video editor is i can
cut that so that it looks like it's the
main point of the entire talk when i
when i do the real
and when you say don't look don't read
into this too much i'm just gonna clip
right after that just so you know oh god
okay that's fine whatever uh that's
that's the life i've signed up for i
guess
um
so yeah like those those were the
results so
similarly effective on average
massively differing responses within
individual and um when i was on
dave tate's table talk
a couple months ago this was a point i
brought up where i think that there is
maybe too much emphasis on
trying to figure out what on average
works well and not
quite as much emphasis on
what works well for individuals and how
to predict what will work well for
individuals like i think uh like study
design should kind of move in that
direction
and really there there are two types of
study designs where you can get it
information like this like not just what
works best on average but like what what
is the sort of
intra-individual variability in terms of
responses to different training
protocols and for that you either need
crossover studies like this one or you
need within subject unilateral designs
and i am seeing
more within subject unilateral designs
crossover studies are are still
relatively rare and for good reason um
you know this study if it was just a
parallel groups design it would be 12
weeks in and out per subject as it was
it was 24 weeks in and out per subject
which you know if you're trying to run a
typical study with college kids makes it
very difficult to do that study because
most of the time people aren't on campus
for six months straight they're
generally going home for christmas and
summer
but anyway a very good study design for
looking in
to this type of
question um
so i think that the
the main takeaway here is this is an
important principle that that you should
keep in mind if you're a content
producer when you're producing content
and when you're a content consumer you
should keep this in mind when you're
consuming content
so
uh if you're someone who's producing
content you you need to be pretty
careful about generalizing your n equals
one experience
to other people so you know in this case
uh
one of these people like let's say it's
a post-menopausal woman with a youtube
fitness channel
and she does moderate load training she
does her sets of eight to twelve she has
a five percent reduction in lean soft
tissue mass of the legs and says hey
look the fitness industry's [ __ ]
stupid they're saying do your sets of
ten for hypertrophy that's going to make
you lose muscle but if you do sets of 27
to 31 dude you're talking about an
increase in lean soft tissue mass of 10
over three months like that's
that's the good [ __ ] um
and so you know that's a very common
issue i think where
like even in kind of the the
evidence-based community like you'll
you'll see where
someone tries something they get good
results with it and then instead of
instead of just saying like hey i tried
this thing here's my anecdote maybe give
it a shot they say well i observed this
thing and it had to have happened for a
reason so let's go into the literature
and just try to find
maybe some mechanisms that could
potentially explain it to
therefore make my anecdote seem super
generalizable and scientific
so that's that's one thing to be aware
of
and also just kind of the key point here
is if you are starting with kind of like
a literature first approach where you
are are going into the research looking
to see what it says
if you're looking at two training
interventions that don't seem to have
differing effects on average
that doesn't mean that those two
training interventions won't have
different effects for a lot of
individuals
and
the the differences within the within
individual could potentially be quite
large um
and if you're a consumer of information
i think it's important
to
like when you read no difference uh like
two things
on average seem to be similarly
effective i i think that a lot of people
have
a kind of positivity bias where
they're looking for things that work
better than other stuff so when they
like when two things are tested head to
head and they seem to be similarly
effective i think a lot of people
subtly interpret that as neither of
these things worked because neither of
them worked better but really most of
the time it just means
either can work and it's probably worth
experimenting with
because once again like those two things
could
like one of them could be much better
for you or much worse um
and i also think it's important when
you're consuming information
to not
immediately assume that a scientific
finding or a piece of content something
creates is wrong because it conflicts
with your personal experience so if you
were one of the subjects in this study
who you know uh had a had a nine percent
larger increase in lean soft tissue mass
of the legs following moderate load
training you know if if you've done that
already that's your experience and then
research on moderate load versus low
load training starts coming out and all
of the science is saying hey it doesn't
seem like there's much of a difference
between these two things on average
you can look at your experience and be
like no that's [ __ ] [ __ ] like
i've done both of these things one of
them clearly works much better
well it works much better for you like
that like just because a finding which
is looking at mean differences conflicts
with your personal experience that
doesn't mean that the finding is wrong
that could just mean that you had an
atypical response um like that's
that's very common and i think that
people uh underestimate how how often
that occurs
and i kind of think that the the whole
notion of conflating average responses
with individual responses i think that
there's a bit of a like an ideological
current underpinning it where like this
is probably a very outdated reference
now like i i don't think
i don't think this film has as much
cultural resonance with the kids anymore
but for people our age and slightly
older the film fight club
and tyler durden's speech you are not a
special snowflake like i think that that
either
was ideologically clarifying for a lot
of people or
uh like you know taking something they
already believed or suspected and kind
of like putting a catchphrase to it or
it was like influential for people who
like didn't have uh
like under underlying assumptions about
the similarities or differences between
people already
where you know that like that
idea kind of sticks in your head of like
no like you're not a special snowflake
i'm not a special snowflake you know
people uh
share like 99.9
of their genes there's there's no way
that you're that different from anyone
else so if we find something
that is generally effective from a
training perspective nutrition
perspective whatever um
if it works pretty well for most people
it's got to work for you too and if it's
not it's just because you're [ __ ]
lazy and not trying hard enough um like
i i think that that's
like
it
it's more it's more wrong than right but
i think that that's just kind of like a
tacit
underlying assumption and heuristic that
a pretty large group of people just go
through the world with um and
yeah like there there are a lot of
instances where things that work well
for you may not work that well for other
people and vice versa like things that
don't seem to be generally efficacious
or not more efficacious than some
alternative on average could be really
really good for you um and and i think
that it that's always worth keeping in
mind like
when we're dealing with scientific
research that is examining
mean differences group averages um you
know your personal experiences will
probably comport with the average
experience
a pretty good chunk of the time but you
shouldn't expect it to comport with
average responses
all of the time or maybe even most of
the time um so that's
just uh yeah that's that's really the
point i'm trying to make and and i
thought that this study was uh
a pretty good just kind of like case
study to to illustrate this point so
eric are there any weird little things
that may not be just generally great
advice uh from a training or nutrition
perspective that you found to work
really well for you personally
yeah i mean the one thing that comes to
mind for me is uh
starting out when i first got into
lifting i
became very fond of the what would be
called the bro split
uh
low frequency per muscle group but very
high volume per session for each muscle
group so you go in and just beat the
[ __ ] out of your pecs for like 90
minutes right and you won't touch them
again for seven days yeah
and you know then i got into the whole
science thing and i start looking at the
research and saying okay well but but
what is what it ought to be the optimal
way to do it right you start putting
together these heuristics and these
guidelines of frequency okay at least
two or three times a week and volume per
session we want to look at some of these
thresholds at which
at which point something kind of gets
more into like junk volume versus like
really high quality volume and stuff
like that
and
you know all throughout the years i've
experimented with different approaches
and
i i wouldn't say that
you know the the kind of more
evidence-based approach works poorly for
me
but
i will say i made
progress on low frequency
training programs that had very high
volume per session
i made really great gains on bro splits
that just don't seem compatible with
kind of best practice guidelines or even
some of the literature uh suggesting
that they are
less favorable that would be the one
thing that that comes to mind for me
what about you
so for for me uh my my one weird trick
that helped
my squats more than almost anything else
was breathing pause squats and so if if
you're if you're an old-school greg head
uh you probably know about these i don't
think i've talked about them publicly
since maybe like 2015 2016 or so
um
but yeah like so my my squats are are at
this point and have been for a long time
my best lift and getting really good at
squats uh
was kind of a two-step process where i i
did two things that may not be generally
advisable first i did kind of like
bulgarian style training like daily
maxes
squatting multiple times per day working
up to a max doing back off volume just
way more than should theoretically be
ideal worked really well for me
and then when that stopped working as
well i
just like i don't even remember how i
came up with this but
i still never felt like really
comfortable at the bottom of a squat and
i felt like i couldn't brace well so i
came up with breathing pause squats
which like i'm sure someone else did
previously but i just hadn't come across
anecdotes of it before where essentially
i'd get a pretty light load
go down
and just like pause for a long time and
by a long time i'm not talking like a
five count i'm talking like a minute or
two so you know i'd be doing full deep
inhales exhales but like still bracing
but not
trying to be like over like
exclusively reliant on intra-abdominal
pressure to brace and like kind of hold
myself there
um
and boy like that that was
probably second only to the bulgarian
style stuff the most effective thing i
ever did for my squat um
and i i fell into the trap of assuming
that since they were so effective for me
they had to they had to be good for
other people too um
and
so i i kind of put that out into the
world and like this this isn't
scientific like i haven't you know uh
recruited 200 people and told all of
them to do it and collected all of their
responses but just in terms of kind of
anecdotes i've heard back from people
who who gave breathing paul squats a
shot
it seems that for
probably about 80 percent of people like
they don't do anything um
like they're they're not bad they're
just not
uh any more productive than any other
squat
auxiliary lift you could do but for
like 10 20 of people they are like
borderline magical where
you know over the span of
three four months they put like
70 pounds on someone's squat uh so you
know that's
like i think a good example of a
an approach to training or in this case
like an exercise that really for the for
the vast majority of people it's not
generally efficacious but if if it turns
out to be the thing that you need
it it like nothing else seems to scratch
the same itch yeah yeah yeah i do think
that you know this is an important
overall point uh to kind of keep an eye
out for these individual level
differences i mean like i said
i've had great responses personally to
programs that don't seem to be optimal
based on you know the the meta analytic
research
so i i still if i'm working with a brand
new client i have no idea about their
training history or they don't really
feel confident in saying
they respond better to this or that you
start with what seems to work best for
most people
and then you individualize from there
you know and i am excited about
you know there are all these areas of
the research where we say
uh well we need more research here but
who knows when we're going to get it
right
i actually very firmly believe that we
will get a lot more clarity about
inter-individual differences within the
next five to ten years in specifically
exercise and sport nutrition i i think
we are on the cusp i know
specific individuals who are working
toward like how do we really effectively
quantify this and model it and make
better inferences about it yeah and that
ball has been rolling
very slowly and people have in some
cases jumped the gun and said like oh
i've got the perfect way to do this then
you look back and say
i think you're you're modeling
measurement error not individual
responses right yeah but i do believe
five or ten years from now we're going
to be able to get much a much better
grasp on
how you know to what extent different
individuals truly differ with these
different outcomes uh beyond just hey
sometimes equipment has measurement
error you know yeah yeah so i think that
it's i think that it'll be a two-step
process where one
we need to be able to quantify the
between and within individual
differences but then two
kind of where where all of this
hopefully is going is trying to find
useful predictors so you know like it's
all well and good to say as we can right
now
ah yeah moderate and low load training
on average seem to produce similar
responses you can look at individual
data and it seems some people do
considerably better with one or the
other the next step is then to say
okay but can we predict which one you'll
do best with right um
and
yeah like i
i hope that's where things are going
i agree
all right ready to move on yeah let's do
it
so greg when you think about raw egg
consumption what comes to mind
man so two things come to mind uh the
first thing that comes to mind obviously
is rocky one um second thing that comes
to mind is
when i started getting into lifting my
parents initially were just like very
just completely against the use of
protein powder or supplements in any
form
so kind of kind of v1 of this before the
raw eggs come in
is
instead of letting me drink protein
shakes just like buy some powder mix it
up whatever um they would only let me
well not let me buy they would buy these
for me i think to to make sure i wasn't
like buying protein behind their back
but they would buy me ensure drinks yeah
like the the stuff for
for like people who can't chew or digest
food well um
man those are
[ __ ] rough they have the
they have the consistency
of sweetened condensed milk like they're
unbelievably viscous and they also don't
have that much protein i think it was
like 15
uh grams per can or something like that
they're like a protein supplement for
someone with
no athletic related uh
goals right right just like getting
enough protein to be a healthy adult
correct yeah uh
and so yeah like
trying to chug two of those after a
workout
was just miserable yeah um so eventually
they relented a little bit and said okay
like you like you can get a basic
protein supplement but initially they
limited me i think to just one scoop a
day and they certainly wouldn't let me
touch mass gainers um but you know i was
at this point just getting into
powerlifting i think i was like maybe
160 170 um and i i've mentioned this on
the podcast before like my
my first training crew were
uh all guys who were
very strong
uh untested multiplied multiply lifters
who had some
in hindsight
unhelpful ideas about how much people
should weigh at particular heights so
you know for them
it's like oh you're you're like 5 10
you need to at least be a 242 probably a
275.
that
probably wasn't a great idea to get
lodged in my brain that young but it did
uh and so i was like dude like i i need
to gain weight and i'm training all the
time still playing sports very active um
so if you can believe it at one point in
my life i did actually have some
struggle with putting on weight just
because my activity level was so high um
and since i couldn't use mass gainers i
had to come up with my own
that in hindsight was was far worse and
just like more inherently dangerous than
just buying a mass gainer would be um
but
every morning i would mix myself up a
mass gainer shake where
most of the protein just had to come
from raw eggs because like i couldn't
use that much protein powder so it would
be
whole milk ice cream peanut butter
uh like a scoop or two of protein powder
and then like a dozen raw eggs and i
just throw it in the blender mix it up a
dozen
maybe it was like eight it was at least
six it was a it was a good number of raw
eggs which i'll note
like so eggs kind of like have a weird
smell and taste mostly from like the the
sulfurous compounds in the yolk but
those don't go volatile and really like
affect the the smell or taste that much
until they're cooked so drinking raw
eggs is not as unpleasant as one would
assume especially if you got some some
ice cream and peanut butter in the mix
but anyway i i'd make i'd mix that shake
up pour it into a half gallon bottle
and just drink on it from the morning
until about 4 p.m
that's disgusting um which is again like
that
so in terms of food safety very bad idea
in terms of like the bacteria i was
ingesting probably very gross on a on a
purely hedonic just like gustatory basis
it was fine like it tasted okay and the
taste didn't get
meaningfully worse throughout the day uh
but anyway in hindsight it is very funny
that they were totally fine with me
consuming like a dozen room-temperature
raw eggs every day
but wouldn't let me use a mass gainer um
but anyway so that's that's the first
thing that comes to mind when i think
raw eggs just i i used to consume a lot
of them yeah in a very dangerous way
yeah and you you mentioned uh the rocky
balboa movie franchise and you know
that's why they were fine with me
drinking the raw eggs like my my father
loves the rocky movie franchise and he's
like look man like sliced alone wouldn't
lead people astray if if he's willing to
put himself on the silver screen
drinking raw eggs they've got to be safe
for my boy yeah i think that was kind of
the thought process well not just safe
but also
effective and hardcore correct right so
like when someone says like hey you know
i'm taking my lifting really seriously
i'm going to have an omelette for
breakfast you just say well
an omelette is just a lovely breakfast
that's not very hardcore yeah but if you
say i'm going to crack four eggs into a
glass with nothing else and chug it
people are like oh [ __ ] you really want
to get big yeah you know and a lot of
that comes from
the kind of
implied connotations from how raw eggs
were featured within the rocky franchise
and i think specifically rocky one
so with that in mind
do you suspect raw egg consumption to be
better or worse or equivalent
when it when compared to cooked eggs
specifically in terms of like muscle
protein synthesis and building muscle
yeah so so now now that i'm a little
older and know no more things
i would assume that raw eggs are
probably worse than cooked eggs
just because like most
most
i think proteins in general certainly
animal proteins as far as i'm aware have
higher oral bioavailability after
cooking just because like the cooking
process
kind of unravels some of those proteins
makes them a little bit easier to digest
and i i believe that's particularly true
of egg protein so i would anticipate
that cooked is is better than raw
so i am going to in this segment cover a
new study that actually directly
compared raw versus cooked
egg consumption
specifically looking at acute muscle
protein synthesis after a resistance
training stimulus so very
straightforward study but before we get
into that i want to take a little detour
and talk about protein quality it's
something i've talked about previously
on the show but not since we had all
these additional capabilities with
adding visuals and graphics and things
like that so i wanted to give a nice
little concise overview of protein
quality why it matters and then circle
back and talk about that study so
first of all uh protein quality is you
know there are several different scales
that are typically used to quantify it
and
academics like to argue over which
scales were best and of course it
changes over time as people win
arguments and create new scales and then
have more arguments and win those
arguments so
if you look back at older research
you'll you'll see and current research
depending on the application people
talking about protein efficiency ratio
uh biological value net protein
utilization protein digestibility
corrected amino acid score i mean
there's a long list of these different
metrics that people use to basically say
not just which proteins better than
another but give me a number so that i
can really start ranking you know large
lists of different proteins and the
general idea behind protein quality is
like to what extent can a human being
consume this and really efficiently and
effectively utilize the proteins within
the food for building new human proteins
and when we're talking about fitness
stuff we're almost always talking about
building new muscle proteins right
that's really what people are are
interested in yeah so
you might be wondering why this matters
uh you know an egg is an egg so you'd be
thinking well these both have the same
protein quality uh but actually as you
alluded to
raw versus cooked eggs you know they
have the same amino acid uh breakdown or
profile
that's one huge component that goes into
protein quality is what amino acids are
in this and in what relative magnitudes
but it's not just the amino acid profile
it's also the digestibility and like you
mentioned many proteins their
digestibility is influenced by the way
that they're processed or cooked
and eggs are no exception there was a
study by ivana poole and colleagues back
in 1998
and i'm going to put a little table on
the screen here but
what we're looking at is the true ileal
digestibility uh and what what's really
fascinating is you might think okay
cooking a protein maybe it takes it from
like 85 digestibility up to like 92
right in the case of of this study they
found that that percentage of true ileal
digestibility went up from 51 to 91
by cooking it so we're talking about a
very considerable difference in uh this
particular metric of protein
digestibility
so with this in mind uh
someone might very justifiably assume a
cooked egg same amino acid profile but
way better digestibility surely this is
going to promote muscle protein
synthesis to a greater extent than raw
eggs
and then again very justifiably they
would say well if it builds muscle
better over five hours you know
literally building new muscle proteins
surely that means it's going to build
more muscle over five weeks or five
years right so we we have this tendency
to say well if it's better for muscle
protein synthesis in the short term
surely it's better for hypertrophy in
the long term
so that brings me to this new study
head-to-head raw versus cooked eggs and
this was by do you know how to pronounce
that last name
i don't f-u-c-h-s i have no idea um
it's probably a german last name if i
had to guess the origin
yeah i i don't know i'm googling it real
quick yeah so anyway uh this study which
actually referenced rocky balboa in the
title
um all right are are you ready i've got
it i've got it pulled up on youtube okay
i'm gonna crank the volume
fuchs pukes
fuchs all right
there we go
hopefully we don't get like a copyright
claim for for throwing that audio in i i
apologize
voxifier.com uh we we didn't mean to
steal your intellectual property uh so
fuchs yeah that that makes sense and it
always makes sense in hindsight when you
look up how to pronounce something but
you're like yeah that was one of the 35
ways i would have tried yeah so anyway
fuchs and colleagues uh like like i was
mentioning they they specifically
mentioned uh rocky balboa in the title
which i thought was kind of clever um
but very straightforward study after a
resistance training session you know
they were they gave these protein uh
uh
treatments right so one group of people
got
uh cooked egg the other group got raw
egg and then a third group was like a
control group and if memory serves i
think they got a lovely croissant with
butter and a little bit of orange juice
nice so it was it was a much lower
amount of protein it was like five grams
of protein the other treatments um going
based on memory i think they ended up
getting like i think it was five eggs
each and so that puts you in like the
20 to 30 ish range for for protein yeah
yeah it was a pretty standard protein
dose for someone who's trying to get a
really nice robust protein synthesis
response
so what they were looking at here is
looking at uh plasma amino acid
responses so just after ingestion
how did key amino acid levels change
over the course of the next few hours so
when we talk about key amino acids uh
there's a few we want to mention so
leucine is a very special amino acid in
the sense that it plays a role in
actually stimulating the response of
muscle protein synthesis it plays more
of like a signaling role of telling the
muscle hey plenty of leucine here let's
go ahead and start building muscle right
and so the leucine is really important
for triggering that response and then
the essential amino acids are critical
because we need all of them to be there
and present in sufficient amounts so
that we can build new muscle proteins so
when you look at these amino acid
responses it's very common to say okay
what does the leucine look like are we
getting a big increase a really rapid
peak
and a sustained high level of leucine
and then same thing goes with essential
amino acids are we getting a really nice
robust response with a really big
increase in blood levels
now i'm going to show on the screen here
the amino acid responses were very in
line with what you would expect right so
looking at blood levels of leucine uh
there was not a large increase
at all looking at the control group with
had which had that really low protein uh
meal
the uh the raw egg group did have a
noticeable increase
it looks like plasma leucine went down
in the control group if i if i'm looking
at the right figure yeah i i should have
put the actual time amount on the uh the
x-axis there i i think that just has to
do with the preceding resistance
training stimulus
that impacts those acute dynamics um but
uh but yeah the raw egg there was a
noticeable increase a significant
increase statistically speaking
but the uh the cooked
uh egg had a significantly greater
increase in blood leucine than the raw
egg so that would go in line with the
the assumption right you cook it the
digestibility goes up we have a better
more robust leucine response compared to
raw eggs
now if we look at total essential amino
acids in the blood it was the same exact
pattern so the control group it actually
dropped off a little bit and there was a
little reduction
the raw egg did have an increase but the
cooked eggs had an even greater increase
so
based on the blood amino acid levels you
would say this is going exactly as how i
would expect and surely we're going to
have a better protein synthesis response
in the cooked egg group because of that
better amino acid response in the blood
yeah so so far this is exactly what i
predicted so let's let's just wrap this
segment up and
yeah that would be nice uh unfortunately
there's a complicating factor here
you're gonna see on the screen here
we're looking now at muscle protein
synthesis rates and what they did was
they looked at kind of baseline and then
they looked at the first two hours after
ingestion and then from hours two to
five and in the first two hours all
three groups had a significant increase
um but then when you look at
uh hours two to five you start to see uh
a bit of of a divergence there right so
when you look at hours two to five you
see that clearly
uh you know
statistical comparisons aside we see a
more robust increase in muscle protein
synthesis when we're looking at the raw
and the boiled eggs compared to the
control group
but when we when we start to compare the
raw and the boiled eggs they look
extremely similar i i mean they are
virtually identical when you're looking
at protein synthesis rates whether
you're looking at baseline zero to two
hours or two to five hours uh and then
once again they they also included a
figure there where they were looking at
uh just overall that whole zero to five
hour time period after ingestion uh
again baseline all groups are pretty
similar looking at that entire five hour
period uh all groups did have an
increase in protein synthesis rates
and but when you look at the actual
magnitude of the increase once again the
raw eggs and the boiled eggs were very
very similar and in fact looking at that
zero to five hour when it's all
collapsed together the raw egg bar is
slightly higher not meaningful
whatsoever from a physiological
perspective but
whatever advantage we would expect from
the boiled eggs having a better
you know
immediate response in terms of amino
acid levels it simply did not translate
to muscle protein synthesis so there was
a favorable effect if you just look at
the the blood amino acid kinetics and
responses but for muscle protein
synthesis there was really no influence
of cooking when compared to the raw eggs
so this comes to a broader point about
protein there is
a chain of assumptions that a lot of
people make and the assumptions build on
each other right and so the chain goes
like this we we look at these individual
protein sources one by one you'll you'll
often see people saying should i have
whey or casein or milk or egg or chicken
or beef whatever
a lot of times we'll look at these
things in a vacuum and say well first
i'm going to look at quality which is
based on amino acid composition and
digestibility and i'm going to assume
that better quality or higher quality
score leads to a better amino acid
response in the blood
and that necessarily leads to a better
muscle protein synthesis response
acutely and that necessarily leads to a
better hypertrophy response over time
helps me build more muscle over time
and a lot of times without explicitly
stating it a lot of people do assume
have a tendency to assume
that those relationships are like
perfectly correlated and also related in
magnitude in a very direct way so
a lot of times people assume if i have a
five percent better uh you know protein
quality score i'm gonna have a five
percent better response in blood amino
acid levels and a five percent better
muscle protein synthesis response and a
five percent better increase in muscle
over time
and what's really important to to
recognize is
if that kind of chain of assumptions
held true there would be things we would
expect to see in the literature that we
should be able to expect pretty reliably
you know so we should expect that the
studies looking at acute muscle protein
synthesis responses with all these
different acute feeding protocols of
this protein versus that protein they
should give us a very clear
reliable and predictable pattern of
which protein sources lead to more
protein synthesis
there should also be pretty clear
relationships by which
animal-based protein sources
very obviously and routinely outperform
plant-based protein sources whether
we're looking at protein synthesis or
long-term changes in muscle over time
yeah
we should see as an extension of that
that vegan and vegetarian diets
do very very poorly in studies compared
to omnivorous diets when we look at
these outcomes of protein synthesis and
hypertrophy over time and really even
among omnivorous diets if this chain of
assumptions held true with the type of
uh
high correlation that that some people
expect you know we should even expect
that people who eat a higher percentage
of animal-based proteins on an
omnivorous diet should have even better
results than someone who says you know
maybe i'm going to go kind of
plant-based and only get like 20 percent
of my protein from animal-based proteins
right so
even within an omnivorous diet we should
see that
a general preference toward more higher
quality animal-based proteins should
win out in the long run
and one thing that's important i talked
a little bit about animal versus
plant-based protein sources the reason
that i group them and kind of categorize
them as lower versus higher quality
that's not a hard rule there are low
quality animal based proteins um
so like collagen
its amino acid profile if you're trying
to build muscle is just rubbish it's
terrible and and the studies bear that
out it is not a good muscle building
supplement when we look at uh soy that's
a very high quality plant-based protein
but overall plant-based protein sources
tend to have lower quality scores what
i'm going to show you is a series of
figures from a study by vanvlier and
colleagues
and
what we see it's a bunch of different
protein sources plant and animal based
and human that's just to give a
representative example that is not
implying you should be eating human
muscle i would discourage that in the
strongest terms possible yeah i mean it
because it has considerably less leucine
than whey so exactly
yet another reason to not eat humans
there's literally multiple reasons yeah
like there are at least two yeah
so uh but when you look at these
plant-based proteins generally speaking
they have lower leucine per gram of
protein
generally speaking they also have lower
essential amino acid levels uh per you
know per gram of protein although i i do
think it's worth pointing out that there
is considerable variability among
animal-based protein sources right so i
i find it a little bit ironic that
people say like oh i don't eat
plant-based proteins or i don't rely on
them because they're such low quality
but you never see those people splitting
hairs between like
whey and egg or or you know whey and
beef right they just consider it all to
be high quality protein but there is
still considerable vari variation there
you know i see on these lists that for
leucine content and amino acid content
cod is particularly low down
low down on the list as far as animal
proteins go which
might make you feel a little bit silly
about trying to replace me with dwayne
the rock johnson is he a baby
if memory serves he's he's a huge cod
head wow which that might make you
question some of his choices yeah yeah
i'll have to think about that i'm still
waiting for him to get back to me which
is strange because i sent that email
three years ago but we'll see
uh now i'm also going to show a figure
here of lysine and methionine
and the reason that this is important is
because
a lot of what we would call a low
what we would call low quality proteins
one of the main factors kind of
dictating you know if we're going to
just split into a dichotomy high versus
low quality like we can give them a
graded score and all that stuff but one
of the issues with a low quality protein
is generally speaking you know per the
definition it's going to be lacking at
least
one essential amino acid
uh so you know
of all the essential amino acids there's
going to be at least one where it's
really falling short in a way that
inhibits its ability to support muscle
building to a maximal extent
and the two most common ones that we
have to keep an eye out for are lysine
and methionine and we're going to come
back to that a little bit when i talk
about practical applications of
plant-based proteins um but but we can
definitely see that for a lot of uh
plant-based proteins you know they fall
a little bit short with either lysine or
methionine whereas animal-based proteins
tend to have plenty of both so so that's
a key distinction between them but
when we look at digestibility when we
look at
essential amino acids leucine in
aggregate
uh animal-based proteins tend to
have better looking metrics than
plant-based proteins
and so
like i said with that kind of chain of
assumptions you would assume well surely
plant-based proteins are going to fall
way short when we look at the literature
for protein synthesis and hypertrophy
but that's really not the case
so there are a couple meta-analyses in
the last couple of years one by morgan
and colleagues one by lim and colleagues
and generally speaking they found that
you know that one of them was looking at
specifically plant versus animal based
the other was looking at high versus
lower quality proteins so like for
example i think there were some studies
in there that used collagen as the low
quality protein even though it's animal
based yeah uh but generally speaking you
know when you look at it uh acute muscle
protein synthesis
the data generally lean
in favor of be of looking better for
these higher quality protein sources and
these animal-based protein sources uh
but there is a there there's some mixed
evidence there i covered it in a mass
article
uh a year or two back where there's
actually a surprising amount of
contradictions in some of those
head-to-head comparisons
but nonetheless overall broadly speaking
generally the research indicates that
muscle protein synthesis acutely is
better for these higher quality proteins
especially when there's no resistance
training involved and that's important
because resistance training itself
provides a very robust stimulus for
muscle protein synthesis leucine and
amino acids aside yeah i mean even going
back to the to the study that uh like
the the main one about eggs that we're
talking about here
i mean it looks like just the resistance
training stimulus itself
increased muscle protein synthesis like
threefold over baseline
and
resistance training plus either version
of egg consumption
maybe increased muscle protein synthesis
four-fold over baseline so like the the
impact of training itself was
considerably larger than
protein oh absolutely yeah training and
having a lovely croissant with some
butter and orange juice
those people were in a good spot in in
terms of protein synthesis there you
know the the extra protein from egg just
elevated it a little bit beyond that
um
so generally speaking you know like i
said better acute muscle protein
synthesis findings for these higher
quality proteins but
when you introduce a resistance training
stimulus
that starts to muddy the waters a little
bit and then when you make the leap and
you stop looking at protein synthesis
and you instead look at things like
hypertrophy or strength development over
time those differences really fade away
and i'm not going to get into all the
nuance and detail of why that's the case
but i am going to refer interested
individuals to a paper by
watard and colleagues called making
sense of muscle protein synthesis a
focus on muscle growth during resistance
training the entire uh premise of that
paper or at least the way i read it was
to explore why
in that chain of assumptions
things do break down along the way and
why we cannot look at a protein and make
a perfect assumption of how it's going
to impact muscle protein synthesis and
even if we could
protein synthesis
those acute studies really do not
predict long-term hypertrophy
nearly as well as we would hope that
they do so a lot of people will say you
need to eat this protein source because
it does way better in these acute
studies on protein synthesis
and those findings generally speaking do
not pan out particularly well for
long-term hypertrophy within certain
contexts you know that that reminds me a
lot of
like emg research like you go back five
six years there were a lot of
like a lot of well-meaning and generally
well-informed people um who
in like you know not throwing shade i
was one of them who would make like
pretty strong recommendations about like
oh you should do this exercise instead
of this other this other exercise to
grow this muscle group because look like
we see higher emg responses with
exercise a versus exercise b
um
and you know like over time we've
learned more like yeah that's not really
a validated assumption and there are a
lot of situations where
that assumption like higher emg leads to
more effective training stimulus more
muscle growth where that assumption
breaks down um and now i think a lot of
people are pretty wise to that but i
don't think
that same level of
i guess skepticism is an okay word for
it has really reached uh protein
synthesis or protein quality data quite
yet yeah and to be fair i mean a lot of
this research is really developing
before our eyes you know a lot of the
research i'm talking about here the
meta-analyses the two studies i'm about
to mention these are all from the last
two years or so right so two studies
that really put this to the test and i
think we're really eye-opening studies
for a lot of folks who
had a tendency to really micromanage the
minutia pertaining to their protein
sources one was by montane and
colleagues and what they did was they
looked at uh
a two two diets one was vegan the other
was omnivorous both provided 1.8 grams
of protein per kilogram of body mass per
day which would be within what we
consider kind of the optimal kind of
general range
and what they looked at was muscle
protein synthesis levels not acutely
after a single meal but longer term over
three days with resistance training
included in that protocol and what they
found was if you're eating plenty of
protein and these diets were
supplemented with a pretty decent amount
of mycoprotein which is a pretty high
quality plant well
it's a
fungi fungi based protein uh they used
to say it was mushroom based but then
they got hit
they ran into some litigation because
people were like this clearly is not a
mushroom and they're like right but no
one wants to eat fungus
but yeah mycoprotein is a fungus-based
uh
protein source
that that fits within vegan diets and
and has a pretty solid set of
characteristics for protein quality
but uh generally speaking
1.8 grams per kilogram per day over this
three-day period uh both groups whether
it was vegan or omnivorous had similar
uh protein muscle protein synthesis
rates over those three days so that
gives us more information than looking
at a single meal but still it's protein
synthesis it's not hypertrophy but that
was covered shortly thereafter in a
study by javier lorraine and colleagues
they were looking at 1.6 grams per
kilogram per day
in a diet that did have a significant
amount of soy protein
rather than mycoprotein
soy again a really nice plant-based
protein with some really
favorable characteristics so i'm not
indicating that protein quality is fully
irrelevant and that's an important thing
these diets had some myco proteins some
soy some other kind of conventional food
products that have that have plant-based
protein so i'm not saying plant uh you
know protein quality is irrelevant you
know just have collagen and you'll be
fine that that is of course an
indefensible statement what what my
general argument is getting toward is
we want to just have a mixture of pretty
okay proteins and that seems to be just
as good as micromanaging and saying well
what if i increase the protein score
from 87 to 92 right the effect of that
is is zero right so i'll get to those
practical applications as we go but
since i highlighted mycoprotein and soy
as being pretty high quality proteins it
is relevant to mention uh but but we'll
we'll put all those pieces together in a
moment but in this case again eating
enough protein 1.6 not a super high
amount right so back in the day a lot of
folks would say well you can do fine on
a vegan diet but you have to eat
way way way more protein than an
omnivore
this study directly contradicted that
and found that over a very you know kind
of standard resistance training study
timeline longitudinal study in
conjunction with resistance training
whether you were on a vegan diet or an
omnivorous diet both groups had very
similar improvements in strength and
hypertrophy so
like i was saying my main premise here
is not that protein quality is
irrelevant that that's an indefensible
statement but it's that we need to
change the way we view that kind of
chain of assumptions and i think we need
to work backwards so the goal here is to
support maximal or near maximal
hypertrophy responses to training right
and if we work back it's not that we
need to start with protein quality score
and build up from there but we need to
work backwards and say in order to get
this great hypertrophy sp response
i need to find proteins that give me a
good enough muscle protein synthesis
response so it doesn't have to be the
best one when we compare head to head i
need my muscle protein synthesis
response to this protein to simply be
good enough yeah and how do i get there
i need to make sure that i have a blood
amino acid response that isn't way
better than all the other comparators it
just has to be good enough to get me
there yeah and how do i get that good
blood amino acid response
i just need the amino acid composition
and the digestibility of that protein
source once again
to simply be good enough uh so these
little mine you know tiny minute
differences comparing one to the other
they don't seem to be that informative
what we need to do is make sure that at
each channel each step of this chain
along the way we need to have protein
sources that are simply good enough to
get the job done which lends itself to
the question
how good is good enough like how do we
go about sorting through different uh
protein sources within kind of a
conventional diet uh not looking into
like hyper-specialized protein sources
or anything like that
and you know it's frankly extremely easy
to find protein sources that are
more than sufficient to support
hypertrophy to essentially to a near
maximal level so uh what we're trying to
do here is over the course of a full day
make sure you don't have any glaring
shortcomings when it comes to essential
amino acid coverage so like i said some
proteins are going to be short on lysine
or methionine you want to make sure you
don't have any massive oversights there
you also want to make sure that you are
selecting and preparing food sources in
a manner that simply
conforms to basic preparation guidelines
you want to cook things the way they're
supposed to be cooked but but generally
speaking if like when we're talking
about these studies with like uh the soy
the soy study the mico protein study
i didn't see anything in the methods i
could have missed it i didn't see
anything where they were saying oh by
the way we also were extremely
meticulous about arranging the other
protein sources in the diet it was just
like hey
you're on a vegan diet let me guess
you're going to be eating wheat and rice
and corn and beans and whatever right
like the other protein is just coming in
from just eating foods that that find
their way into kind of standard typical
diets
now that leads me to a question greg so
so the overall goal here like i said
no massive shortcomings for essential
amino acids uh and just eating stuff in
a preparation method that is advisable
and making sure that you're not having
any stomach discomfort due to poor
digestibility
a lot of omnivores
start to
you know
go in line with that original chain of
assumptions and say oh crap
i need to make sure that i have all of
the highest quality protein source
except a lot of people don't realize
like they'll make like protein oats and
be like well i put in 24 grams of whey
protein so this meal had 24 grams of
protein it's not the case oats have
protein and usually more than people
think yeah so usually omnivores who are
into into lifting will make that
realization it's like oh my god
a considerable portion of my diet is
crappy protein i mean i've seen people
even put forth the idea that like you
know the the 1.6 to 2.2 grams of protein
uh per kilogram per day or whatever
that's uh that's specifically just for
high quality animal protein yeah like
like you should be aiming to get that
much animal protein in per day not just
total which
is directly counter to the research well
i was going to say i don't want to be an
[ __ ] but like
that that range of numbers comes from a
study yeah you can just look at the
study and say is that what these numbers
mean correct and they don't yeah but
anyway yeah back to being nice and
charitable
so
some people will say like crap i need to
really tighten this up and stop counting
all my lower quality plant-based
proteins and only count my high quality
ones from animal sources so greg
what percent of daily protein
in an omnivorous diet comes from plants
rather than animals if you had to guess
oh man
so
this
isn't my guess now because we've talked
about this off mic before but before we
talked about it off mike
um
just kind of like based on
my assumptions about my own consumption
habits before i started tracking i would
have guessed that about maybe three
quarters of the protein in an omnivorous
diet comes from animal sources so
about a quarter from plant sources yeah
so when i started digging into this
research my assumption was that the
percentage coming from animal based
proteins was much higher than it
actually is
um
and i think a lot of that comes down to
demographics that inform those
assumptions so i'm going to put a table
on the screen here that talks about the
breakdown of animal versus plant-based
proteins in a diet now the world
worldwide average for an omnivorous diet
is 42 percent of protein from animal
sources and 58 from plant sources uh
that's a much higher contribution from
plant sources than i would have expected
but then when you start to break down
things based on uh socioeconomic status
and you break things down into regional
uh localizations
you start to see that there are very
clear patterns so like for example in
the americas um
we have we have a pretty you know
decently high percentage of our protein
coming from animal-based sources
whereas when you look at uh africa and
asia for example there are lower
percentages coming from animal-based
protein sources so part of that is uh is
regional
it also breaks down a little bit
differently as you go from lower income
to higher income uh categorizations but
yeah the the the take-home there is that
in fact a decent percentage of protein
in an omnivorous diet across regions uh
does tend to come from plant-based
proteins and that's fine because when
you look at
even a small contribution from
animal-based proteins you are still
getting
plenty
more than enough of leucine and
essential amino acids lysine methionine
the whole deal so if you're on an
omnivorous diet that isn't like 90
plant-based
you really don't have to put a lot of
effort into scoping out these
meticulously curated lists of protein
sources but that brings me to a vegan
diet
and i've mentioned on the show my diet
is getting closer and closer to vegan as
the years go on it's strictly vegetarian
but kind of flexible with uh with dairy
and egg but uh
a lot of people say well i'm a vegan so
i can't really lean on that assurance
that i have some animal based protein
coming into the diet so what do i do
here right so
sometimes vegans will who are into
lifting will think man this sucks i'm
gonna have to look into like this huge
list of like nine essential amino acids
for every single protein source and
really carefully kind of fit this puzzle
together and fortunately that's not the
case practically speaking
when you look at
plant-based protein sources we can
categorize them in a very convenient and
efficient way so a lot of the common uh
plant-based protein sources we'll see in
the diet
can be categorized based on the
particular essential amino acid that
they are coming up short on so
i'm going to put a graphic on the screen
that's from bodybuilding.com
i i understand that you know food
selection is regional so these
categories aren't going to be perfectly
representative of every region of the
world but this was looking at stuff that
you might find in like you know these
are all food sources i would expect to
see in an american supermarket walking
down the aisles
but
there's a group of proteins that are
missing threonine and lysine and so
we're talking about oats rice rice
pasta rye wheat corn
there's a different group where you're
missing methionine so beans lentils
peanuts chickpeas peas and soybeans
there's also a category where you're
where you're specifically missing lysine
so that would be walnuts cashews sesame
seeds sunflower seeds
pumpkin seeds a bunch of seeds and nuts
basically
so what's really convenient about this
is when you categorize protein sources
basically all you're trying to do to to
to meet the um to meet your needs for
amino acids is just make sure that
you're not picking all your proteins
from one of these groups right you want
to have what they call complementary
protein sources which basically means uh
if if all of your so your protein
sources that you're currently going to
seem to be missing methionine so if
you're just like hanging out totally in
group b
just try to work in some protein from
group c right and so what you're trying
to do is mix and match these groups a
little bit and it doesn't have to be
perfectly done it doesn't mean you have
to have 50
50 of your protein from group b and 50
from group c or something like that what
it means is you just want to have a
mixture from multiple groups that are
making up your daily protein intake and
as long as you're doing that and you're
meeting basic general recommendations
for protein intake
everything else seems to sort itself out
just fine so those general
recommendations which are important uh
based on the literature
you want to make sure that you're
getting at least 1.6 grams of protein
per kilogram of total body weight per
day or if you do a little bit of math uh
that generally breaks down in most cases
to aiming for at least two grams of
protein per kilogram of fat free mass
per day that's for if you're like
approximately trying to maximize muscle
growth right yes if you are trying to
cancel
that absolutely yeah this is for
optimizing hypertrophy this is not for
supporting general health yeah yeah um
general health basically you you'd cut
these in half right yeah usually you'd
go 0.8 grams per kilogram
um
is that how it how it goes i think
that's yeah yeah we the fitness industry
has so uh aggressively [ __ ] on the rda
for protein that i've i've
basically forgotten what it is yeah but
yeah yeah i'm i'm pretty sure it's point
eight yeah it is it is um but yeah so
those those are the targets you wanna
shoot for again if you're trying to
maximize hypertrophy you're lifting
you also want to split that protein
ideally if you can into like three to
six servings per day how important that
is is subject to debate a lot of what we
know about those specific protein
distributions a lot of it's based on you
know acute studies that lack ecological
validity some of it's based on studies
that don't involve a resistance training
component which like i said uh provides
a not just a large but also a
long-lasting stimulus for protein
synthesis but if you're interested in
optimization
it shouldn't be too terribly difficult
to break your protein into somewhere
between three to six servings per day if
you say listen i got to do it all in one
meal that's fine based on the literature
doesn't seem to be optimal but you can
still go a very very long way with that
strategy in terms of hypertrophy and
then again you just want to make sure
that there are no glaring lacks of any
particular essential amino acid and all
that requires is making sure that you're
not literally getting all of your
protein from a particular group like we
mentioned previously with those
complementary protein categories you
just want to make sure you've got some
pro some proteins that have plenty of
methionine some that have plenty of
lysine
generally speaking threonine is it's
important but you don't have to work as
hard to to make sure you've got it
covered usually you're gonna have enough
to get the job done
so um
i think that covers a huge percentage of
questions and concerns related to
protein intake and
again uh
you know
the general uh general take-home point
here is
it's probably not
uh beneficial to get too bogged down in
the details about micromanaging
really you know small differences in
specific protein sources what you're
trying to do is hit those general
recommendations have a nice mixture of
proteins in your diet you should be good
to go two caveats i want to mention like
you alluded to this entire segment was
basically assuming that you lift weights
and that you're interested in maximizing
hypertrophy so that that's an important
caveat or kind of clarification to add
on there
this is not like a
segment about general health guidance
caveat there might be situations where
an individual is restricted to a low
protein diet for medical reasons
not my place to say what those reasons
should be if you're working with a
qualified health care professional and
they need you on a low protein diet
they'll let you know not me on youtube
but in that scenario if you're like okay
i'm i am restricted to a lower protein
diet
but i have an interest for for a variety
of reasons and getting as much strength
and lean mass as i can
that is a specific scenario where i do
think protein quality could become a
more pertinent issue because what you're
trying to do there is basically get more
bang for your buck and focus on
protein efficiency you know so what is
the smallest total grams of protein i
can ingest while getting maximal benefit
for supporting hypertrophy
and strength gains and
most almost certainly if you've got a
qualified health care professional
telling you to restrict protein you're
going to be well below the intake that
that meets those general recommendations
i gave for lifters so in that case
that very specific kind of unique
situation
i do believe it makes sense to then
prioritize higher quality proteins it
doesn't mean a protein score of 94 is
totally different than 91 but you will
probably want to prioritize just so that
you can try to get all your bases
covered with leucine and essential amino
acids without having to take in you know
1.6 grams per kilogram per day
makes sense
cool so no more questions about protein
we never have to talk about it again uh
yeah seems like it awesomes like it
no i do enjoy talking about protein and
it is one of those there are some of
these areas of the nutrition literature
that are egregiously understudied
protein fortunately not one of them
there's plenty of literature to dig into
and uh yeah i
everyone in nutrition loves talking
about protein we've talked about that
off air it's like
everybody's favorite little topic
whatever their perspective happens to be
all right so i think that does it for
this episode right it does uh as always
thank you so much for joining us for the
stronger by science podcast
we will be back soon with another
episode
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you could sign up for the free
newsletter at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you